I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her
happy Valentine's Day what a great day
to talk about a shitty romantic movie
called Twilight in the year 2008 movies
like Iron Man The Dark Knight wall-e
these films were huge and awesome and we
also had movies like Twilight and
according to the Los Angeles Times
Twilight is a full-blown pop culture
phenomenon would you agree that Twilight
is a full-blown pop culture phenomenon
yes does that mean it's good Twilight so
in preparation we not only watch the
movie but my wife reread the entire book
mercifully you did that and I didn't
thank you for doing that thank you for
taking that sacrifice dogface they did
it for him that's why I did it
oh I don't like the puppy-dog face thank
you for for doing that
yeah so the movie opens with Bella
played by Kristen Stewart blandly
narrating everything for us because
that's just what all these movies are
like there's always a teenage character
who wants us to feel angsty about their
angst because they're very ankle with
angst the book is exactly like the movie
and feel I guess and just monologuing
and depression and angst that was great
yeah it only took me 36 hours to read
what usually takes me six what Twilight
has going forward is that it's pretty
it's a good-looking movie everyone's
pretty and there's there's faces that
are pretty and the location is pretty
the location is pretty the people are
pretty the CGI is terrible
the Belle is the new kid at this high
school she has the nice kid who comes up
and tells her where everything is
because you always have to have a
character that tells the audience
character who is Bella where everything
is just like in Mean Girls if you guys
saw me and girls were Mean Girls she's
not a bad movie there's always the
audience character the new person who
needs to get information and exposition
from everybody so you have the nice kid
come in and go hey you're not very
popular and you're new but we're just
gonna be super nice to you because
you're hot cuz that's so how high school
went yeah not for me me either when I
was a new kid in school no one spoke to
me no one when I was in school nobody
spoke to me
I've gone to school with them for 12
years yes the school sucks
don't go to school is basically what
we're saying just you know go to school
please go to school school is good go to
school
so Bella meets Edward and for whatever
reason Edward has an incredibly adverse
reaction to her it's very apparent like
he's a fan
right they make him smell her a fan is
blowing and her sense is wafted to him
and he's just like oh you can just tell
like instantly he hates being near this
person apologies camera angle change
apparently my last camera which is a
slightly better camera decided to die on
me in the middle of that review so you
get the lesser camera but the review is
still going to be the same from us so
next in the film we get some amazing
dialogue enjoy I don't really like the
ring any cold wet thing I don't really
what does that even mean like what why
who talks like that nobody talks like
that no I like Kristen Stewart as an
actress now I don't have a
predisposition for any particular actor
or actress I like to judge them solely
on whatever they're actually working on
and not
oh well it's this guy's it's gonna be
good for all exactly no I just would
rather judge him on with the film
individually not as a whole I agree with
you but in this movie she's terrible
she's awful she mumbles through the
entire film I think he brought out that
she blinks endlessly just nothing but
this all the time and she's constantly
like just always you always seem like
she's trying not to poop yeah like she's
just on the cusp of pooping and she's
trying so hard not to for that direction
look like you're about to cry and poop
at the same time you have diarrhea yeah
okay currently Catherine Hardwicke the
director this entire movie was made by
women yeah I know
the author is a woman the screenwriters
a woman the directors a woman and elite
stars a woman and for some reason our
lead female character is useless this is
something that we're gonna talk about
here she gets rescued every other scene
she can't figure things out in every
scene and she doesn't get to make any
decisions on her own that's like no
decisions are bad a girl who can think
for herself oh my what is the
coming to that was one of the worst
characters I think ever in a big-budget
popular movie
there are worse movies and worse
characters but most of those films
aren't as popular as Twilight is yes for
a film this popular and from a book that
popular this character is terrible
there's nothing about her there's
nothing interesting about her
it really isn't even in the book there's
really nothing interesting about her in
the book they don't even give her
backstory like didn't she even have a
life in Arizona it's never even talked
about she had any friends did she have
any hobbies the only thing to talk about
is that she likes to read and that she's
a bit of an introvert that's like not
she has depression I think that was her
character in the book she's pretty much
that same way through all of the books
just a weak character mercifully I have
not read these books my life I'm glad
you're still sitting here alive it
nearly killed me another thing that is
very very apparent in this movie is that
Edwards a giant stalker he watches her
across the parking lot he follows her
around town he even says this I like
watching you sleep and for whatever
reason Bella's fine with that because
he's just so hot this is a terrible
relationship it's mutually abusive
relationship
and it's a very destructive relationship
there's even like blogs online the pages
designated to how destructive the
relationship of Edward and Bella truly
is if you start reading it it's just
like oh my god it takes like everyone in
the box of an abusive relationship at
least in the emotional category sure
there's also a lot of googling in this
movie I mean Google must have paid them
a lot after Edward saves Bella she's
like obviously you know questioning I'm
like how'd you do that
I had an adrenaline rush it's very
common you can google it what like what
it's so stupid like I mean it's like
almost like the filmmaker is like
thought maybe the audience doesn't
really know what Google is even though
everyone knew what Google was yeah oh
just throw in some Google and later in
the film she does another Google search
and start suspecting that Edwards a
vampire this is such lazy storytelling
it's such a lazy screenwriting it's like
we can't think of a way for Bella to
suspect this we'll just have her search
google because that's early I'll figure
out that
I mean you took the boxes of being a
vampire honey you're okay yeah I don't
like a sign
I look like Edward hmm
I don't think Robert Pattinson's that
like the tractive to be honest okay yeah
he's he's hard to look that guy that's
him saying that
speaking of product placement there's a
lot of Twizzlers in this movie I'm get
it other than maybe it's a reference to
blood looking candy maybe all I could
think of is that whizzers was like hey
can you just have scenes where
everyone's just like you know munching
on towards lairs because we like money
maybe it was because Twizzlers are red
and everything else of this movie isn't
that an XK love grey that they needed
something to at least contrast at a
couple points so they used this Whistler
that was in the contract that was in the
contract they were like Twizzlers look
this entire movie is a dull gray color
palette everyone will notice the
Twizzlers everyone you will make so much
money everyone who loves Twilight will
one eat Wizards I yep put them in depth
whizzers yep I'm wondering if at the
screens they handed out boxes of toys
ladies I wish I went to screenings in
2008 so I can know what gift they gave
attendees let's talk about some of the
line delivery in this movie it's
amazingly bad
whoa what is going on if I came home
from like a store or something and there
were cop cars outside the house I
guarantee the first thing out of my
mouth would not be whoa what is going on
I'd be like holy shit I better go check
I wouldn't be like well it's even her to
watch you do that talk like that I have
to admit that there are so many lines
like that in this book that are just
like wow what must that be like and I
have marked up this book with like notes
of just what were they thinking when
they wrote this there's nobody like stop
to read this aloud I can see why I took
you so long to read it cuz like every
two seconds you're like that's not do
you see that that sucks
see this yeah well honey what must that
be like I don't know I waited 369 pages
to get to the plot of the book what must
that be like painful you heard me trying
whenever is reading this didn't you what
must that be like whoa what is going on
I'm trying to find the page they marked
it now here it is I waited and read all
of this till page 328 to get a plot what
must that be like terrible so as we said
Google makes Bella suspect that Edward
is in fact a vampire and he decides to
reveal herself himself he's a girl
whatever
he looks like himself/herself fuck it he
reveals himself to Bella and he's
sparkling in the Sun and she says cute
that scene spawned one of my favorite
lines ever that made fun of another
movie inside of a movie and that is in
Hotel Transylvania right when Ladd is
crawling up the plane yeah I'll show you
the clip tell me do you dream of being a
vampire this is how we're represented
unbelievable yeah that was amazing I
remember just sitting in that movie
screen that just made the entire movie
for me that all right right there thank
you yeah thank you that was great stuff
in a kid's movie no less so it's
probably one of the better jokes an Adam
Sandler movie even though it's not
really an Adam Sandler movie but it was
probably one of his better jokes our
first date that was our first date so
eventually Bella becomes unconditionally
irrevocably in love with Edward and we
get a ton of montage sequences hang on
spider monkey with more horrible CGI and
jumping around trees and piano playing
and laying in fields and you know stuff
teenagers do and yes and then we lead
into they try to make out with the
world's slowest kiss didn't like this
movie everything is so slow
well this is super awkward I said okay
if I just kind of smell you I really
don't like this this is uncomfortable
can I just okay one thing that that is
not is romantic and for whatever reason
Twilight thinks it's romantic and this
it's awkward and really that's this
whole movie it's just a very awkward
movie when Bella meets Edwards family
that's understandably awkward but the
majority of this movie is cringe-worthy
in regards to how awkward it is meeting
your family no but when you're not a
vampire and all the family members are
vampires you know there could be a
little weird I guess and especially look
it's okay because they're vegetarians
yes Aryans they're nice vampires but
there are bad vampires and one of them
finds Bella in the middle of a baseball
game where Bella's the umpire it's the
American pastime it is the American
pastime Mel is the umpire despite not
being able to actually see what's
happening is everyone so fast she's the
umpire I needed more scenes that were
just dumb like a like a vampire baseball
game if Twilight was more
tongue-in-cheek
I'd probably like it but it's so serious
more dumb scenes though you know what I
mean like just scenes are so silly
like vampire baseball the entire film is
so self serious that one scene was like
like hey we're being stupid and we're
playing baseball cuz there's lightning
like I can deal with that but when the
entire film is just so like like you
know teen angst it's just it's we need
more dumb scenes like that the baseball
field probably is the funniest scene got
it the whole thing it's very uneventful
it takes them to like the fourth act
before Twilight invented a fourth act
it's cuz you moved through three
different acts before you get to that
one it's like Taco Bell the fourth meal
Twilight has before that if you think
about it think about how it the movies
cut up yeah it doesn't go to the one two
three goes to one two three four and
then five
but once the plot finally happens
there's a bad evil vampire that for
whatever reason wants to hunt Bella
because he smells her and he decides to
place serial killer games with Bella by
filming her with his camera and playing
weird mind games by taking her to the
ballet studio she went to when she was
young and pretending like he kidnapped
her mother these are things he never did
earlier in the film he just hunted
people and killed them now he's like a
serial killer because we need more time
for Edward to show up to save her which
of course he does and we get this really
overblown action nice sequence with
wires and flipping Bella really wants to
turn into a vampire and this is her
opportunity Edward doesn't let her
though and he sucks the blood out of her
she ends up in a hospital and for
whatever reason no one including her
father who's like a police officer or
any of the doctors question the
incredibly obvious bite mark right here
on her wrists that anybody anywhere like
a baby would be like uh you got a bet by
a doggy
like anybody would know that was a bite
mark yeah and no one screenplay writing
right things learn how to write they
don't even write that in the book never
explains it either ah
and of course Edward does not allow
Bella to be a vampire despite the fact
that she is literally begging him to
allow it because women don't get to make
their own decisions apparently how do
you feel about that that's what I
thought and ugly Jacob is in this movie
I call him ugly Jacob because he's got
the long hair and he's not so by the way
it was totally illegal when new moon
came out and everyone was like oh my god
Jacob so hot yeah yeah gross
you know what's fine he's only in the
like three scenes in the movie right
he's basically there just to remind us
there's gonna be a love triangle yeah I
think you know I in too in the book he
applauded you for watching them all
because I think I've only seen the first
two but see you've read the books and I
have not so we even each other out in
that way
you've suffered through the books I've
suffered through the movies that's are
hilarious the review of Twilight's if
you didn't guess we don't really like
the movie ah I've been like trying to
process it for like a week now and it's
just not gone very well it was actually
like I noticed I was like why are you
acting so different you're like I'm
reading Twilight I'm reading it okay
just leave me alone it was like it was
really like literally had a psycho
depressive 36-hour
just like me the hell alone back off I
need space I'm gonna finish this book
guys thank you so much for watching this
hilarious T review of Twilight happy
Valentine's Day
if you don't celebrate Valentine's Day
happy day be happy it's a day don't
watch Twilight
no don't pretty soon I'm gonna have
another hilarious T review for you I'm
actually not sure what it will be I have
a few different choices three different
movies that are kind of going along in
my head right now but after that I'm
gonna have a new series of hilarious 'ti
reviews for you guys and that is gonna
be for DC comics movies leading up to
Batman V Superman because DC Comics
movies there are a lot of terrible ones
like really bad we have an easy time
picking them - it's true we have a very
long list there is a very long list and
I can tell you now my very first one is
going to be for Supergirl the movie from
1984 not the new TV show so look forward
to that that's not gonna be next week
there's gonna be a surprise - layer
yosity next week but after that DC
comics movies guys thank you so much as
always for watching thank you honey for
suffering through this with me thank you
very much okay if you like this you can
click over here and get stuck tonight
here have an Edward toy Thank You Sears
I just toss it and retire me I fucking
found it in a bargain bin it's obviously
a bargain bed did you look at the page I
want this thing my god